13 buses were targeted 12 were
completely burned and I want to
say it my first message is obviously
a message of indignation of the cures
when we see in the public service who are
affected
hello everyone
and we sometimes have the feeling that
some of  they live in the street
the video games that have poisoned them there
is an acceptable exploitation
of the death of a teenager that we
all deplore while the period
should be meditation and respect
[Music]
I understand the color of young people all
completely normal I understand it but there
are limits to everything but there is a
moment you have to know when to stop
[Music]